Bà Thóc Câméra là cảnh dung chuyển khi vụ nổ gió gió gì khi gà sẽ giá đẹp thường ăn phụ đông thành phố Hô Chí Minh.
Sư việc sẽ giá khoảng 4 giờ ngày 2 tháng tạm tại các nha cấp 4 giọng khoảng 4 mệt vương trong hẹn đường hào vý giáp
cách bên sè ngã từ gà khoảng 2 chăm mét.
Thế điểm sẽ giá vụ nổ bên trong có khu ba bệnh biệt bà tuổi và châu trai bà mi tùy.
Nó bệnh lời rõ rí gà đẹn đó.
Nó bệnh tiếm hả có thể ngọt kẹn lời như bà tránh thất.
Qua nè, gió bệnh tiếm chân nhé.
Tại vì gà nè tương một cái hộ vụ nhé.
Nhẹ tương lớn là, vừa người lời.
Chá chá bị nổ vậy đó.
Tương là và ăn bây giờ nhỏ đi ra hớt.
Trời khỏi thử dạy, chương lời cũng lối ná khó bụng.
Bộ nổ lắm các nhà tốc mái đô đặc sáo trộn hư hệ hoàn toàn.
Anh hưởng vụ nổ cũng làm hai cân nhà bên cạnh nước tường bệnh kiến là phòng.
Đại diện phương ăn vụ đông cho biết, nhớ chá ban đầu sát định dây dẫn bình gà bị rõ dì khi
tích tụng trong nhà khi chúng nhà bật mấy bấm nước, tiếm lực biệt phát sinh gây nổ,
hay bà cháu bị thương nhẹ và đã xuất viện sau khi kìm chá sự khỏe.